القوات البحريه الصينيه والروسيه اليوم
مناورات المشتركه في مقاطعه اجيانك شرقيه
الصين وقالت البحريه الصينيه ان قواتها
التابعه لقياده المسرح الشرقي وقياده
المسرح الشمالي الصيني ستشارك في
التدريبات الى جانب القوات الروسيه اضافت
البحريه الصينيه الى التدريبات تهدف الى
تعزيز الجهود التعامل بشكل مشترك مع
تهديدات الامن البحري وكذلك حمايه السلام
والاستقرار على الصعيدين الدولي الاقليمي
وزياده التعميق شركه التنسيق الاستراتيجيه
الشامله بين الجانبين
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن تدريبات عسكريه
روسيه بلا روسيه مشتركه في مقاطعه برست
قرب حدودي بولندا غربيه بيلاروسيا اضافت
الوزاره ان تجربه تاتي في اطار الوقوف على
جهازيه القوات الاقليميه المشتركه بين
البلدين